alyssa is with us in Dallas hi Alyssa
how are you I'm great Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up now I
bought a car at a totally no place that
I thought I needed a couple years ago I
am now extremely upside down with a high
interest rate shorted harder than
qualified to be refinance due to the
miles and the loan-to-value and I'm
unable to get a loan due to my own
credit now how do I get out of debt
faster should I just get it repo'd and
pay the settlement and I have a little
bit of money to buy it a beer a Buick
all right now how much how much how much
you owe on the car I owe 14,000 and what
is the blue book on it Kelly Blue Book
Oh about 4,000 oh now you sure 14 is the
payoff and not the total of payments yes
it is the payout like I just ordered a
payoff statement and it's actually 14 to
48 for my payoff and that's when I
bought the car they in order to buy it
they required that I buy the warranty
and another service that kind of jacked
up the price I'll cancel the warranty
can you can't right now and apply the
reef under you're down until your deal
because you probably got $4,000 warranty
oh I didn't know that and any of the
other services that are in there that
you can cancel and apply them to them to
the balance that'll help you anyway
what's your income about 45,000 okay
yeah cancel any of the services in there
that you can cancel any insurance or
anything that they've got built into
that these people ripped you off about
six different ways I mean you really
really got desperate and man they just
took you to the cleaners uh I see that
now yeah I'm so sorry what a mess um I
think you're probably going to fight
your way through it because if you hand
them the keys they're going to come
after they're going to sell a car for
nothing they'll sell it for $1,000 and
come after you for another extra three
that you don't have to I mean you can
sell the car but um and if you could if
you can borrow the difference I
be one thing but as you said your
credits messed up I don't know Chris you
seen any high desert yeah I really don't
see a way out of it outside of a you
know working an extra dino for me if I
was in this scenario I would work an
extra job and there's no way out of this
without making like major monster like
$1,500 payments with a halftime of that
part-time job and maybe it's like 650 no
dollar payments or something like that
but yeah I don't I don't see a way out
of this
ouch yeah the big payments with the
extra job cancel the warranty but I know
if you turn it in to them they're gonna
they're going to sell it for nothing and
come after you for even more unless you
can pre negotiate a settlement with them
if you pre negotiate a settlement with
them that's you know gives you four for
the car or three for the car cuts out
the warranties and that kind of stuff
and so you end up with a you know seven
or eight thousand dollar loan and then
go get you a beater I would do that but
if you but don't just walk in there and
toss them the keys and hope this works
out all right because these people have
not been known for taking care of ol
Alyssa you know that they've not they've
not taking good care of you so you got
to be really have your guard up with
this mess hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider rinsing
right over here or click the link in the
description below